forget that the comic books ever existed
in the movies of the MCU there's still
so much about the relationship between
the Hulk and black widow that's just
plain strange let's take a long
unblinking look at all the bizarre
elements about the Hulk and black widows
relationship with the 2015 film Avengers
age of Ultron writer and director Joss
Whedon surprised fans by pairing the
Tasha Romanoff otherwise known as Black
Widow with Bruce Banner who transforms
into the Hulk their relationship hasn't
gone too far in the films at least not
yet
murders rampages brought on by psychic
assaults and epic battles with armies of
robots always get in the way because
they always do the romance wasn't
something anyone could have predicted at
least not before Avengers age of Ultron
went into full swing
that's when viewers began to take a real
interest in those scenes featuring Black
Widow touching hands with Bruce banners
more monstrous half the story is no
equivalent in the pages of the comics
Bruce Banner and Natasha Romanov barely
have any connection with one another in
the source material other than the fact
that they both been members of the
Avengers but the movies tell a very
different story don't they the first
on-screen meeting between Bruce Banner
and Natasha Romanoff certainly doesn't
look like love at first sight at the
beginning of the Avengers Black Widow
was abruptly pulled off an assignment in
Russia to recruit Bruce Banner to help
find the stolen tesseract shield
evidently new banner was in Calcutta and
managed to track him down
Romanov hires a little girl to lure
banner to a Shack outside of the city
under the false pretense that her father
is sick once black widows trap is
revealed she uses her sex appeal and
lies to draw banner closer she tells him
there's no one outside waiting for him
and that Nick Fury's interest in him has
nothing to do with the other guy you
know the one
smelling a rat banner purposefully
brightens romanoff getting enraged so
that she reveals her true intentions
no one's gonna put you that's when Black
Widow contacts all those supposedly
non-existent shield soldiers with all
their high-tech weaponry of course these
aren't exactly the solid foundations of
a nurturing long lasting relationship
and can we talk about the fact that
Black Widow felt the need to lure banner
into a shack and so she hired a little
girl to shamelessly lie to a guy who
turns it to a giant green monster when
he's upset it's all very very Shady
facts are deal-breaker we know it isn't
easy to fluster black widow because
she's a master at keeping her cool in
dangerous situations in fact the only
time we've ever really seen her go off
the deep end was during her first
encounter with an enraged Hulk in THE
AVENGERS
when Bruce Banner turns into the Hulk
aboard shields Helicarrier we catch a
glimpse of joss whedon's directing
prowess when it comes to horror Romanoff
hides from the Hulk and the bowels of
the ship but once he finds her she
doesn't stand a chance
and one of the most memorable scenes in
the Avengers the Hulk crashes through
the Helicarrier and Hot Pursuit a black
widow eventually backhanding her into a
wall before being interrupted by Thor
afterwards we see Black Widow is quite
shaken even though the battle is
continuing throughout the Helicarrier
she's sitting in the corner and clearly
recovering from the terrifying encounter
it's the only time we've seen her like
this in any of the films it seems a
little crazy that the very same man who
inspired this trauma and a team full of
handsome and mostly single men should be
the one that she's drawn to the most in
case you didn't know the Hulk and Banner
don't like each other very much
they don't consider each other the same
person and they really don't like it
when they're praised for the qualities
of the other there are plenty of
instances where the Hulk seems resentful
or even jealous of Banner
Man vice versa your brother's friend his
friend before you betters friend and
when you think about that a victorious
scene and Avengers age of Ultron seems
to take on a much darker tone when
banner frees Black Widow from Ultron's
prison and suggests they run and go into
hiding she lures him in for a kiss and
says I adore you
but I need the other guy stop to think
about the negative feelings Banner and
the Hulk have for one another
consider the emotional and physical
torture he goes through when he's
transforming the fact becomes clear what
black widow did here was pretty bad at
least as far as potential girlfriends
are concerned after all she's seen
banner painfully morph into the Hulk
herself let's just say this incident
would be high on the list of issues for
the two to work out and couples therapy
Black Widow is a professional assassin
and an expert at hiding in plain sight
and Captain America the Winter Soldier
she knew how to get trained professional
soldiers off her scent with only a
moment's warning in fact these kinds of
evasive tactics are like second nature
to the former Soviet agent if you're
ever on the run and suddenly need to get
right off the grid Natasha Romanoff
would be a very good friend to have but
Bruce Banner well not so much in the
wake of the Hulk's rampage Banner knows
he'll have to go back on the run and
when he tells Black Widow he has to go
she responds can you assume that I have
to stay but if you think about it how
could Romanoff ever consider going on
the run with Bruce Banner in order for
their love affair to work they'd have to
hide themselves and remain hidden while
remaining ready to drop everything and
run at a moment's notice
could Black Widow live that way sure but
how could she live that way with Bruce
Banner they'd need to keep a low profile
it also needs to go unnoticed and keep
their cool how could a guy who changes
into a green monster whenever he can't
find the remote ever be trusted to keep
a low profile and how could he go
unnoticed
really how could Bruce Banner ever be
anything to natasha romanoff but a
cinderblock chained to her ankle at the
end of Avengers age of Ultron Romanov
asks Nick Fury if he foresaw the romance
that developed between she and banner
his answer is a little vague but he
implies he saw the potential telling her
you never know you hope for the best
then make do with what you get so what
did Nick Fury see and banner and
Romanoff that made him think they'd be a
good match was it a simple matter of the
old cliche about how opposites attract
perhaps more importantly why did he
decide to act on it how would fury
benefit from banner and Romanoff being
in a romantic relationship does he think
it might help keep banner in the fold
does he hope romanoff will be a
fail-safe an easy way to take out banner
if he needs to we may never know but we
know he did it for a reason
Nick Fury is a calculating man after all
plus manipulating a Master Assassin and
a man who occasionally turns into a
Green Monster is inherently dangerous
business obviously he wouldn't have done
it if he didn't think it was important
we doubt he really enjoys playing
matchmaker the Hulk has a penchant for
scattering crowds of scared soldiers
dodging missiles and tearing through
airplanes meanwhile Black Widow is a
former agent of shield which is an
outgrowth of the US military an
organization that's never taken too
kindly to the Hulk's antics that's why
when she appears in that Shack in the
Avengers spanner knows exactly the kind
of person he's dealing with he's dealt
with the likes of her before and really
that makes his feelings for her even
more strange
by the time Avengers age of Ultron opens
banner has won some trust with the world
at large but he knows how quickly that
can change and it does change were their
relationship to go any further Romanoff
might one day be put in the position of
having to assassinate banner or at least
try strange bedfellows indeed when
banner and Betty Ross are hiding out in
a motel in the Incredible Hulk the close
quarters and raw emotions mean things
get hot and heavy real quick oh and
Edward Norton plays the Hulk in that
film in case you're wondering whether
banner just underwent another remarkable
transformation
luckily for Ross and every other guest
at the motel banners wearing a heart
monitor on his wrist when they start
making out before things go too far
banner cuts things off because his heart
monitor starts BP
we hated getting physical with Rossi
soon learns doesn't seem to be an option
when he's sharing a body with the Hulk
of course it's possible that all that
has changed as we saw at the end of the
Incredible Hulk and the end of the
Avengers Banner has more controllers
transformation than he used to
but that control is still rather shaky
we saw him change in the Avengers we
also saw him change during scarlet
witch's psychic assault in age of Ultron
and in Thor Ragnarok we learned banner
had no control when he became the Hulk
and stayed the hall for two whole years
in fact he apparently doesn't even
remember any of it considering all that
how could black widow ever consider
risking her heart and her life of course
on the other hand Mark Ruffalo is pretty
dreamy why did the Hulk decide to leave
at the end of age of Ultron of course
there were plenty of reasons for him to
go at the time it seemed like a rather
selfless move but the events of Thor
Ragnarok really shine a new light on his
actions we know for a fact that the Hulk
never changed back into banner for two
years after the events in age of Ultron
we also know banner wasn't in control
for most of that time banner tells Thor
that in the past he felt like both he
and Hulk had some control over their
actions but for the two years between
age of Ultron and Ragnarok banner claims
the Hulk was in sole control of his body
tonight each had a hand on the wheel but
this time it's like he had the keys in
the car and I was locked in the trunk if
that's true it wasn't banners choice to
leave Romanoff The Avengers and earth
it was the Hulk's choice and if that's
the case it seems clear he did so so he
could remain the Hulk indefinitely
we know Black Widow has figured out a
way to lullaby Hulk back into banner and
we know it was the video recording a
Black Widow that triggered Hulk to
finally change back to banner and
Ragnarok we don't know where electrons
headed but you're going very high very
fast so so here's the theory for you
even though natasha is the one who
pushed banner down the hole to summon
the whole perhaps the Hulk left earth
not in spite of Natasha but because of
her perhaps he wanted to remain The Hulk
because he didn't want banners
relationship with her to put him back to
sleep do you think we're onto something
here or have we gone completely
that check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about the Marvel Cinematic Universe are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]